yo
literally yo
that's hell bro
man are some are going to hell yeah bro
bro
and they just get away with these things
they just get away with these things you
know it just doesn't compute with me
[Music]
right guys
oh my god i need some water that tequila
has licked my tonsils bro
what's good people happy monday fun day
best day of the week second best podcast
in the world chilling with your favorite
duo j money
and it's just you know it's a good day
to be alive it is a good day to be
watching us it's a good day to be
listening to us
spring is springing and yeah man the
sun's about regardless regardless
depending on the country you're in is
what the word i was looking for
depending
um yeah man it's a it's a good day it's
a good feel it's a good vibe it's a very
good feel it's a very good vibe and guys
today is a very special day
a very special day because
fear doesn't have a job anymore
fear doesn't have a job anymore
your boy has finally quit
his
job guys
guys i'm a full-time podcaster gang i'm
a full-time podcaster i no longer work
in totality
i can do this for the rest of my life
for you guys and
it's because of you guys that i'm able
to actually say this today
so i know i said it in the patreon
episode last week but
thank you honestly thank you so much
guys because you have given me the
ability and you've put me in a position
where i can
one be there more for my friends and my
family and not have to think about going
to work and have to give up my weekends
and have to like book days off oh yes
bro booking days off and poking times
off all of that was such malarkey man i
would always miss out on different
things
and it just it used to give me the
maddest fomo the maddest fomo and yeah
man
i am very very very happy
very happy that i can finally say i no
longer work in hospitality and yeah man
that's down to you guys so i thank you
guys so much so so much for that for the
bottom of my heart and funny enough that
was going to be my fun fact of the day
oh was it that that is my fun fact i
stole it from you it's fine brother oh
fine i'm happy we're on the same page
because you knew as well
i'm happy you're on the same page
because you knew as well bro like it's
been so overdue he's the apart from like
bella who i live with he's probably the
only other person i complain to about
work and it's um
it's been a long time coming i've been
complaining about it since the beginning
of this this podcast so yeah man finally
guys you will never have to hear me
complain again
if i'm complaining it's probably just
going to be about this and it's probably
going to motivate me more so yeah my
left yes
[ __ ] goal
man to man
camera aside microphone inside i'm very
happy for you
i'm very proud of you i'm very happy for
you thank you i'm more proud of you
because of like your mentality shift
okay cause i remember
early days when you say earlier early
podcast early pod days okay i rang you
or i message you or whatever once i know
what you're going to talk about yeah and
i said to you
how much would we be after making for
you to quit your job yeah
and your answer was basically
you could be earning five bags a month
from the pod something around these
regions
between three and five bags a month from
here and you would still work because
then you would have five bags plus worth
yeah yeah and i remember thinking you've
lost your mind yeah
you've lost your
mind yeah yeah yeah um
why you would choose to suffer like that
i don't know yeah um but yeah as fam and
then
fast forward a couple years
you were yeah how did you notice when
unprovoked yeah fam i'm very happy i'm
very proud of you thank you well done
thank you welcome to freedom thank you
it's been nice over here i can't imagine
bro the weekends have been weekending oh
it's uh
i never have to work a double weekend
shift again brother
i don't think you understand what that
means to me oh i can imagine i can only
imagine it means the world because it
means the world to me on your behalf
so i can only imagine it means
ah it's it's these 11 11's you've been
saying just willy nilly 11 11 saturday
11 11 sunday and then obviously i have
to travel down here we have to recall
all [ __ ] day mentally
i'm exhausted physically yeah i'm
exhausted oh fam
that means now you get to on a sunday
you can sleep from early fresh oh on a
monday night you'll be rocking a break
on a monday
yeah gang [ __ ] yeah it's been a long
time coming this month
has been the longest month because i've
been looking forward to the end of it
for so long yeah and it feels like it's
dry yeah oh 100 i remember saying like
as soon as you that
every notice i've ever worked in my life
has been the biggest drag of all time oh
it's drag
and i've only been working three days a
week oh yeah yeah i've only been working
three days a week since january yeah
and it's tracked bro ah
then back-to-back doubles
are not for the faint-hearted nah i'm
not doing it
yeah
thank you guys your boy's free
i'm here now
i've stepped in the in the shoes of
jimmy he's he's free as well he's been
free for a minute and yeah it feels good
it feels great man
it feels [ __ ] great it's finally
happened it has finally happened yes
um so thank you so yeah we'll probably
make a bit more content for you guys now
that yes
maybe yes maybe we will yes yes um
speaking of more content guys
if you enjoy the episodes you get every
monday you already know what to do you
need to pause the episode right now head
on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
we are trying to build a ridiculous
community we want to have the biggest
patreon in the country going we want to
have the biggest patreon in the country
um
there is a tiny little pod over
in liverpool
called have a word
and they crush it over there killing it
they crush it over they've got every
single scouser on patreon yeah yeah
they've literally got everyone in their
city somehow managed to convert into
patrons it literally doesn't make any
sense so guys we need to smash those
guys we do we need to especially because
they're just cocky at you with yeah
they're just cocky they just lay their
dick on the table and they're just like
what are you going to say to man biggest
patron in the country and we're like nah
man we're not going to have that anymore
because our patreon is up up up it's
scary we're popping up so what we're
going to do guys
patreon.com gigs you've got over two
years worth of content over there to
catch up on and every single thursday
you've got a brand new episode every
single month you get to zoom me with us
and uh you get a consistent 30 off from
now on on the merch so head on over
there today guys and let us know what
you think um also guys if you are
watching on youtube please subscribe to
the channel chirp sitting in the
comments like the video if you like the
video it helps us tremendously and we
appreciate it every single time it's
done and the numbers keep going up and
up and up and up and we obviously are
trying to build a cult-like community in
the log cabin in um
iowa
ohio idaho idaho yeah uh
somewhere
in the blissful terrain uh in the us
really really just no man's land really
secluded uh we need breeding grounds
white robes and yeezys is the uniform um
and guys uh let's uh let's make that
happen 2023 is where we're going to head
over there and we're just going to clap
cheeks sleep and eat that's it and laugh
and laugh that's all we're here for
that's what we're going to do so just
get on over there as fast as possible
um
and lastly guys if you are listening to
the smooth mellow tones of your boys
firelord fuegs and jmoney here on
spotify apple podcast google podcast
wherever you listen to your podcasts
please uh follow us subscribe to us and
leave a review
por favor
because it makes a massive difference to
our channel it lets us spread the word a
little bit more and um it means who had
can
can never get a job moving forward
because all welling could quit in but
then if you have to go back in three
months and you you can't say face and
all this stuff is embarrassing you don't
want to bash your boy like that i'm not
going back regardless i'm not going back
yeah
yeah
um so yeah guys thank you so much for
that okay guys so
we're gonna mix up the uh format a
little bit today and i'm gonna do in my
the [ __ ] off the bat okay nice and
early off the bat am i the [ __ ] so
let's uh let's give this one a go
okay cool so this one was sent from a
nice gent on patreon and this is a bit
of a different one
yeah
it's a bit different okay it's a bit of
a different one i'm gonna lie to you bro
okay so let's uh let's have a read of it
so
i 16 male have had a paper round for
five months now
um i
think some info is in order first so
context
this paper round consists of me
delivering 1 265
magazines to houses in my surrounding
neighborhoods within five days and i get
60 pound for doing it as i am 16 i had
to do this in my mother's name and she
agreed so she just transfers me the
money when i get paid i only do this
once a month
i was given the job by my mum who said i
needed to earn my own money and be
responsible been there brother
been there at first i was very happy to
do it and for the first two months i did
it to completion
um
sus um
i couldn't resist sorry right
at first i was very happy to do it and
for the first two months i did a
completion pause despite my legs hurting
or how much i complained
pause
yo
all right come on man let's take it
serious sorry brother sorry sorry sorry
right let me pull it up
at first i was very happy to do it and
for the first two months i did it to
completion
pause despite my legs hurting or how
much i complained because i wanted the
money
[ __ ] hell
man
one month i figured out that the people
don't check that i deliver all the
magazines
and i could do a certain amount that i
pleased and dumped the rest if i felt
lazy
i now do this all the time okay
since this discovery i have been dumping
half of the um i've been dumping half
and delivering the rest and the amount i
deliver decreases every month as i
continuously get lazier yeah
it started it's literally started i've
been feeling guilty about this
especially since my mom could be hit
with a 500 pound fine if they check the
magazines and some haven't been
delivered
every month i have been getting paid no
problem so what's the harm right am i
the [ __ ]
i think in hindsight yes you're an
[ __ ] but because of the fact you're
not getting caught you're not an [ __ ]
that's the only way i can see it because
right now he doesn't feel like an ass
well he feels like an awesome because of
the possibility of him getting caught
which will affect his mum
that's why he he's he's posing the
question but when he gets paid every
month he's living lavish he feels lavish
it's true
but
i would say okay
i've literally only just had a thought
i'm gonna let you finish your thought
but i've
got in my mind the only plausible way
that makes you not an [ __ ]
but i'll let you finish first and then
i'll say it
is you know so
he's he's gonna have to take the l and
be an [ __ ] i think because
he's putting he's not necessarily
putting his mom in a sticky situation
like five bills i'm sure she can pay
advice the inconvenience of having to
pay and the thought that
his son or her son or rather has been
scheming and lying and he gets caught
that's the
that's the crux of it in my opinion so
yes
in hindsight you're an [ __ ] but if
you look here in a different angle
you're not an [ __ ] as well because
if you're getting paid 60 pound a month
every month without getting caught
who's not going to do it yeah
um so the thought that just popped into
my head
is and for starters i wouldn't
necessarily be so trusting that the mom
can just drop five bills of course no of
course not yeah yeah that bill's a lot i
know i know that's the reason why i've
seen why he he he mentioned it yes of
course um so in my head
the only way you're not an [ __ ]
is if you've got the five bills
to pay if you get get caught
and your mum doesn't have to drop a
penny so if you're willing
to risk getting sacked
plus have the five bills to give to your
mom if they're hitting with this fine
then in my opinion you're not an [ __ ]
because you're just playing the game
playing the game you've got yourself
you've got your your your bases covered
there's going to be no victims here the
only victim is going to be you when you
get sacked
but if you're playing this and you're
taking your 60 quid a month and you're
spending it on yourself
knowing that there's a possibility that
when not necessarily if when you get
caught because you just said
every month it gets less and less and
less and less
when you get caught
you're willing for your mom to have to
pay 500 of her own money
to cover your back
then yes you're not an [ __ ] you're
you're a massive prick yeah you're a
massive prick but if you can
save 500 pounds
over the course of however many months
you're going to do this for and then
live lavish after that
just to make sure your mum's pattern no
matter what then in my opinion you're
not an [ __ ] you're just playing the
game if that's if they're not going to
check then they're not going to check
and you're literally just playing the
game but if you're going to make your
mom take the fall for this
knowing that she will pay it because she
hasn't got she legally doesn't have a
choice
then you're you're you're you're you're
scummer yeah because the whole thing is
under his mum's name as well yeah you're
scum of the year yeah yeah yeah
you're saying is that you're i'm risking
it
and the worst case scenario is i'm gonna
i'm gonna feel a belt at the end of this
worst case scenario i'm feeling a belt
yeah and my mom's gonna have to take the
rap because what if your mom doesn't
have five bills to spare yeah well she
literally doesn't have it i mean he
doesn't i don't see any possible
opportunity for him to even have the
five bills of his own like you get 60
pound a month yeah so this is what i'm
saying he's going to have to if he can
keep him up for like a year five months
minimum to get the five bills
so i don't see five months minimum what
am i talking about that's 300 pounds
what are we talking eight months seven
months something around those lines uh
let me let me just check
what is it five bills 500 divided by 60.
uh eight months eight months
but
that's
without him spending a single penny yeah
it's eight months minimum to have the
five bills and he's obviously spending
it so it's like easy but that's the
that's that's what i'm saying that's the
risk of the game bro because at the end
of the day is um yes granted
he has to
um save that money
but
if he
sacks off the job
before before he gets caught then that
money's his true so it's a win-win true
but if you end if you can keep it up for
eight months
or spend half of it and do it for 16
months i don't know what you want i
don't know how you want to play it bro
in the but in the world of vermont the
[ __ ] unless you're doing that in my
opinion you're a massive [ __ ] i hear
you i
yeah yeah makes sense
makes sense you are also yeah you are an
[ __ ]
because i know that's not what you're
doing yeah yeah yeah the fact that
you're on patreon i know that's not what
you're doing
true man's using at 60 and splurging on
whatever you want to win i know you're
spending three on patreon yeah minimum
yeah i know you ain't saving every penny
but um yeah bro unless you're gonna save
at least
to um help with the situation granted
like i said i don't think it's a
necessarily a plausible situation that
you've been saving every single penny to
then give to your mom but you need to be
saving sutton broth you need to have at
least half there you need sat in there
that when it does happen be like ra i
[ __ ] up here's all the money i've
saved use it on the fine like it needs
to be something substantial i don't
expect you to have the whole five bills
but if you've got 250 if you've got
three satin i don't know anything bro
because you can't let your mum run this
fine when it happens because if you
think for a second you're the first
person that has a paper route you
thought of the genius idea to dump it
yeah you're off your head
there's a reason there's a fine there in
the first place because they expect you
to do it
there's no way i'll be doing a paper
route i've never done one i'd never ever
ever see see myself obviously back when
i was younger do one ever so yeah my
little brother had one and it looked
long i can imagine because i remember he
had to like
fold up the papers he has to they all
get delivered to the yard and then you
have to fold them in this specific way
so even before you're doing the delivery
you have to do this three-way fold put
it like in the bag
go out on your bike deliver all the
papers come back to the yard fill up
again go to the next neighborhood
deliver all the long
do you remember pennies
pennies it wasn't much
it was long fam i'm not doing it um oh
there's no way i'm doing it i remember
my mom cussing me of course why didn't
you get paper wrap of course your
brother's younger than you he's got he's
he's worked about himself getting a
paper i was like
[Laughter]
what's up guys you know it's that time
again monday means manscaped and
manscaped means monday okay so let's
share some live live let's shed some
love over to our boys at manscaped um
who are
legitimately the global leaders in men's
below the waist grooming and have
forever changed the grooming game with
their
amazing performance package
4.0 okay i have changed the game change
the game with the performance package
4.0 so inside this ball care bundle
tongue twister there inside the ball
care bundle you'll find the lawn mower
4.0 trimmer the weed whacker ear and
nose hair trimmer the crop preserver
bull deodorant the crop reviver toner
performance box of briefs and a travel
bag to hold your goodies come on now
there's so much stuff in there man i
know there's a lot of you man that has
never even heard of ball deodorant never
even heard of balls yeah you don't even
know what realm you're stepping into the
game is about to change so guys all you
need to do is simple you need to head on
over to manscape.com
punch in three little words sng sierra
november golf sng sierra november gold
sng yara november golf that's going to
get you some 20 off the entire
basket
plus free shipping
global
global 20 off free shipping manscape.com
punch in sng sierra november golf and
we're good to go let's get back to the
episode come on
you're off your head if you think i'm
doing this yeah no for money
what's what do i need money for you
i'm 16 i don't need money yeah what do i
need money for bro
for sweeties
cinnamon i can go without yeah if you're
tossed in cinema or this
no cinema is yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
fine i'll take the l i'm not doing all
of this i've been against work my whole
life
i still to this day don't know why but
i've been against work my whole life i
know g it's weird but apart from [ __ ]
that i want to do of course you don't
like working for other people yeah i
just don't like working for other people
like tell me to
diet for 16 weeks
to get on stage and [ __ ] do that and
that's for free
if i want to do it i'll do it yeah tell
me to [ __ ]
do this podcast for god knows how long
we were doing it before we made a single
penny
buy all the equipment do all the editing
learn how to edit do the sound
engineering all these things for free if
i want to do it i'll do it
but yeah
tell me to do something just for p
that is
death and i don't care about the p i
probably should not do
i promise you i'm not it just doesn't
make sense it literally doesn't make
logical sense i don't you you might live
in a simulation i'm not doing that
i have to commend you for your um
for when for sticking to your guns and
certain things bro
it's true i have to
honestly have to
um
thanks i guess
it's not it's not even a backhanding
compliment or anything it's a fact bro
you're very stern with
what you know you do and don't want to
do like when we used to work at um
[Applause]
bro as much as i i think that was one of
my first not my first job it was one of
my first few jobs and i just stuck
through until i didn't do it anymore i
think well after a few weeks you were
you were gone oh yeah i think i made it
like three weeks you were gone bro you
didn't you didn't care i was like damn i
don't want the money i was like oh i was
thinking i want the money don't you have
yeah
it baffled me cause don't you want the
money
fresh work
[Laughter]
i remember thinking i want the money
but i don't want to do this more than i
want the money
[Laughter]
i want to be in bed right now
more than i want the money these men are
going to pay me so it's a no in my head
it's a no-brainer yeah plus there was no
going home time yeah
the golden home time was when the job
was done yeah and i remember seeing boss
man
whoever was running the thing i
literally remember he used to stand up
on the balcony
and tell us what to do yeah scrub under
the tables pick off make sure there's no
chewing gum on anything i remember
thinking you're not doing nothing
you're just better telling everyone to
do something you're literally not doing
anything yeah and you think you could
just tell man
no i'm sick tomorrow and i'm sick the
next day and i'm sick the next day and
the only ones i liked doing
was working the day shifts the day
shifts were very very very few and far
between but i think i only went like two
of them get there for like 10 so you
still get to like wake up at a
reasonable time you get there for 10 you
serve no one all day apart from
alcoholic students yeah who rock in
before between lectures yeah and grab a
quick shot oh my days and then you can
judge them in silence yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you might have to do a bit of
a stock check and then you and then
those days you go home when you when
your shift ends at three you're going at
three so of course yeah because it's
[ __ ] what else to do of course fam those
ones were paying but the whole
evening thing you start at eight nine
whenever it was supposed to finish at
three but you don't leave till five yeah
but you're not paying me till five yeah
yeah you're paying me till free because
there's no i don't see a clock out
machine here
yeah you're paying me until three yeah
i'm not a mug
i hate oh oh i hated it yeah i remember
the day they bailed me to say don't come
back
i remember the day they built it i was a
harvester
i was at harvest i hunted down some red
devil sauce that's what i was doing
because i called in sick for the ninth
day in a row
i just oh that's hilarious i hate oh i
just
hate working for people would you i do
hate working for people i hate working
for um
i hate the idea that like you can put in
more work and not get anything more out
of it
it just doesn't
make sense yeah yeah i completely agree
bro
you said it was you've used this as an
example like if we put a thousand hours
into this we're gonna make ten thousand
pounds more yeah like if someone says
like bro i need you to do
x y and zed or if you said bro like can
we i know um we're recording on monday
but i've got some extra content ideas
can we record on wednesday as well i
know those extra hours on wednesday
we're going to make more money we are
going to be so it's fine yeah yeah it
makes sense yeah let's do that because
we'll make more money yeah
but the whole like oh can you stay late
can you do this or can you do that or
like we've got this much to get through
like you've only got an hour left in
your shift but we've got this to do can
you like [ __ ] bust your ass and do
this for the last hour it's like cool
more money yeah no same money
but if you don't do it you're sacked
it's a weird situation in it it's weird
bro but
yeah man i'm happy i'm out i don't know
i'm very happy i'm out of that now i'm
happy you're out of it [ __ ] i'm happy um
and it's funny because you know we had
the conversation we had the conversation
a little while ago about um
deserve
okay tell me the terminology between
just oh if you deserve this oh yeah
deserve the money and it's all these
things
and um one half of me was like yes the
other half of me was like not really
um because doctors deserve it
but um
i spoke to one of our boys about it and
agreed in terms of like
i would agree that you deserve it based
on having the bollocks
to do it
because there's
in another dimension
where you go down the same path there's
a version that's the exact opposite of
this
there's a version where you kill
yourself for two and a half years and
get
nothing for it and you chase your dream
for two and a half years
flat out every monday every thursday and
you try your absolute best yeah and you
invest time and you invest money and
passion yeah and you see
zero
benefit
and you go back to your nine to five and
you go back to your job
broken [ __ ] broken yeah out of pocket
out of time yeah
your dreams literally shattered yeah you
don't know what to do with your life
anymore you feel like you got no purpose
there is a version of that
so
there i would agree that you deserve it
for even taking that risk yeah because a
lot of people won't take that risk
because
that other version just even saying it
sounds [ __ ] tragic
a lot of people don't take the risk man
um and
i feel like
with us we we are very very lucky what i
say literally me and you like we're very
very lucky in the sense that
one we
somewhat our adult life we kind of grew
up together like we've known each other
for x amount of years we went to the
same uni we share similar stories
and we happen to have great chemistry
hence the reason why this is plausible
you know yeah yeah
without that background without that
basis
i don't think we would have lasted this
long of course not do you know of course
we are very very and also we are very
fortunate in the sense that
it's the both of us on the show if we if
you really wanted to do this which you
really wanted to and i decided to
comment as a guest for example to do an
episode with you or a couple episodes
with you
and it was just your show
it may have also panned out very
differently oh 100 it wouldn't have
lasted fam so
yeah we are we are very very very
you are very lucky in that aspect and
other people don't have that other
person they they can depend on or talk
to or you know bounce things off yeah if
i'm it's true and even the people that
do sometimes it just doesn't work it
just doesn't work it doesn't work out um
and it's [ __ ] grim and that happens
i'm not even going to say some people it
happens the majority of the time yeah
yeah
um yeah [ __ ] there's only 10 there's
only 10 spots in the top 10 podcasts
there's literally 10 literally are only
10 spots
i'm not bragging it's a fact
it's a [ __ ] fact google it we're in
there
you know it's totally taking two and a
half years but we're in there you know
that's so jokes
um it's not our fault
but anyway you've got a uh trash news
now
yes um i saw this on ladbubble not too
long ago um it's about mike tyson
i'll be loving mike tyson yeah so
obviously we all know about um mike
tyson he's got his hotboxing he's got
his weed farm and all that stuff right
well i think i know what you're going to
say but yeah go on the edibles yeah
there is
mike bites you my bites
oh so for those that don't know um mike
tyson for evander holyfield years ago i
think it was like 1997. it actually was
1987. he fought ivana holyfield 1987.
and in that famous fight he bit a piece
of evander holyfield's ear off
so mike tyson has now created edibles
called mike bites which are half bitten
ears
as edible treats which i think is
[ __ ] genius of course i think it's
[ __ ] genius but yeah i'm a read is
just the synopsis so tyson has made a
huge amount of money in the world of
weed and now it appears his next venture
includes selling edibles in the shape of
an ear with a new product being labeled
as mike bites smart as [ __ ]
the edible is of course in reference to
tyson being disqualified for biting a
chunk of evander holyfield's ear during
the wba heavyweight championship title
in 1997.
tyson was fined three million dollars by
nevada state athletic commission for his
actions and didn't fight again for over
a year while doctors performed a
90-minute procedure to try and save
under holyfield's ear that's so peak
the bizarre incident is still talked
about to this day but despite the
shocking nature behind the earbud the
pair have since patched up the
differences but yeah that's what the um
yeah i've seen it that's so smart it is
hella smart and it goes this smart um it
reminds me of what i was saying the
other day about um
like cancer culture yes and like leaning
into your villain yes and just being who
you are and you owning what you did and
all these things and people can't cancel
you this is like bro like he did the
worst [ __ ] thing you can do
and like if cancer control was the thing
back then he'd be done yeah he wouldn't
be able to fight yeah he wouldn't be
able to fight again like you'll be done
at it but he's open about who he is he's
open about this [ __ ] scary guy who's
got someone with serious mental issues
to the fact that he can bring out
an uh a weed edible in the shape of the
ear in the the literal v in the in the
image of the villainous attack that you
committed yeah and people are going to
go crazy for it crazy probably just only
who you are you probably sent a care
package box to you vanda holyfield's
yard oh probably in a very probably
probably but i'm off back to mall off
yeah it's i'm impressed man that's good
he's a genius he makes cake food i know
he does he makes
cake i know he does who had
it's crazy bro tyson makes money bro
crazy bro i know i know from the podcast
the hotbox wheating from this mike
mike bites from his endorsements
obviously from p boxing or ah
yeah he's got that um obviously he's
doing like the retired boxing thing as
well making me from there and he's he
makes money bro he's a business man and
he's always high off his tits i don't
know how he manages to get anything done
oh bro whoever's working in his team is
doing bits yeah yeah yeah he's out of it
half the time
it's absolutely ridiculous um but yeah
man if i play to him that's cool
um
before we do the
uh funny funnies you said you had a
little game time so
have you heard
have you heard of the game word or
that's been going around oh my god yes
i've heard of it so you know do you know
the context of the game yeah so
basically get i'm pretty sure this is
what you do right um so you
correct me if i'm wrong
it gives you a word
or you try uh it gives you yeah it gives
you a word right it doesn't give you a
word what does it give you it gives you
nothing it gives you nothing gives you
enough oh that's it so yeah it gives you
just the let like how many letters are
going to be in it yeah the number of
spaces you've got yeah so you make up a
word yeah that fits like a five so if it
gives me five blocks yeah i type in a
five letter word
and if any of the
letters
are in it it will tell me and if any of
those letters are in the correct place
it will tell me yeah so if i know
there's an a in there but it's the wrong
place i just need to find other words
and you've got a certain amount of tries
to find your word right exactly okay
cool yeah exactly that fam that's
exactly what i would want to talk like
i only because i've seen it being
tweeted before oh okay in terms of like
it doesn't tweet the actual game it
tweets like
blocks in terms of the colors of whether
you've got in got it in the right
position or not and i see i've seen it
so many times and i think what the [ __ ]
are these man tweeting are these man
typing this in
like where is this coming from yeah
where is this [ __ ] coming from it was
baffling me for weeks
um and then i had
seen the name wordle and i probably
associated you but couldn't care less so
i didn't really pay mine to it and i was
talking to one of my colleagues the
other day
um
this was when i was obviously still
working there and she was telling me
i think she was asking me if i played
the game
and i was like big man i've been hearing
about this talk to me about this game
because i'm getting angry i'm getting
angry now i'm seeing everyone i don't
even understand why you know
then she literally said exactly what you
said but it's um
you it's a it is five letter words and
you get six tries oh it's always five
letter words always five letter words to
my knowledge anyway oh okay so my
knowledge always five letter words and
you get six tries to guess the word of
the day
it's there's one word every day same
word every day and it resets every 24
hours so at midnight it will reset so if
i've got the word right
the same word would be yours as well if
that makes sense throughout the whole
thing interesting so you were right in
the sense that let's say the word is
like i've done the one for today on the
way down um on the train
um
let's say um i've typed in smart
but the s is in the right place so the
word s will light up greed
um the m the a the r the t
let's say the t
is
in the word but it's in the wrong place
it will light up yellow yeah and
everything else will be great because
they're not in there yeah yeah
i was racking my brain did you manage to
get it i got the one today yeah i got it
in three tries and i wrote my first word
was um
what did i write
i covered something like teams or
something like that and i got two of the
letters of the i've got one letter in
the right place and two letters yellow i
was thinking [ __ ] so i started racking
my brain right and the good thing about
it is obviously it shows you the
it shows you the um keyboard so you know
what letters you can kind of pin it with
yeah so for example t was in the right
place so i was thinking there's no other
things that could really go with t
either then t h t e t h so you can
actually like
and i got this the second one i got
wrong and then third i was thinking
i was thinking t o no t e no t and what
t h
ah
i forget that t h is a ting you know you
start to lose your mind with this oh
yeah i bet bro and i wrote it because i
got t in the right place and i got r in
the right place yeah and i wrote there t
h e i r yeah
got it going the third try so i was like
yeah it's it's going to be your new
thing it's my new thing it's it's a
brain teaser it reminds me of sudoku so
much yeah even though it's not nothing
to do with numbers yeah it gives me that
same kind of brain spasm and i love it
brain
but you know what i mean like it's like
sparks something oh 100 yeah yeah that's
a good teaser it's a really good teaser
that's uh so what a man on twitter uh
throwing up spoilers no that's the thing
it froze up like remember i said to you
it just shows you if you've got the um
the letter in the right place it shows
you the color green yeah the gray gray
gray and yellow it will come up with
like um five
six rows of five um spaces of different
colors so it could be like green green
grey grey grey that'll be green green
gray yellow yellow then that's how it
comes up in school yeah that's how it
comes up on twitter to show
until they've got green green green
green you know cool and i see that but
it doesn't show anything else
what the [ __ ] are you man tweeting
interesting what the [ __ ] are you man
tweeting it baffled me for time bruv
time
that's jokes but yeah i finally now
understand what it is and yeah man i'm
involved all right calm i'm involved
i'm involved i'm outside it's not i
don't think it's an app because the girl
that sent it to me sent me a link yeah i
think it's online there's an online
thing yeah yeah i might jump on bro it's
it's
yeah yeah man it makes you tap into
something else
makes you tap into something
yeah that's that's what i'm on right now
all right it's a good game so far what
um
instagram segment have you got for us
today oh
so this one
was it wasn't one that i did
via socials it's one that i
found on socials that i just
wanted to regurgitate so this lovely
brother
um he
he tweeted his name is jack deveraux
ladies
what is the worst lie you have heard
come out of a man's mouth
and the
quote tweets and
replies oh wow i yeah we got sent this
bear time isn't it yeah i haven't read
really any other i think i think i've
read one which sweetened me but uh yeah
yeah we got sent out quite a few times
and and i'm a twitter constantly so i
think i saw that prior to even seeing
the dms of the ones we got from
cool you know
and yeah um
let me let me read them out before i
find them again
cool
so again
ladies what is the worst lie you have
heard come out of a man's mouth
bet
i found a bra in his suitcase and he
said it's from he said it's from when he
was fat years back he said he had saggy
titties and kept him to remind him of
how come how far he's come from his
weight loss journey
can you imagine
fam
that's hilarious that's a lie
big man that's
that's too formulated
he's he's had that ready just in case he
ever gets clocked bro that's hilarious
saggy titties back in the day i just
keep it as a memento
[Laughter]
as a bit
so this next chick said my friend says
she found a pregnancy test but it was
negative then a boyfriend said it
it's his he wanted to see if it worked
on males too
but that doesn't even make sense
sometimes mandem don't even think when
they speak bruv
oh my god
this one time i got discharged from
hospital early i walked in on him
smashing another chick
i was still weak so i passed out
i woke up in our bed when i confronted
him he said it was probably a bad dream
i had from falling
[Laughter]
yo
literally yo
that's hell bro
man are some are going to hell yeah bro
bro
and they just get away with these things
they just get away with these things you
know
it just doesn't compute with me
next one
said he booked a hotel room because he
needed the wi-fi
[ __ ] hell
that's why
that's wild
he disappeared for three weeks during
december he came back he came back after
christmas and said he went for a second
circumcision calls were not allowed
[Music]
watch my boyfriend at the time buy
another gold buy another girl a drink at
the bar and he told me he was networking
[Laughter]
jesus
saw
i love you text from his note i saw and
i love you text from his notifications
when i asked him to unlock his phone he
said he forgot his fingerprints
that's the dumbest thing i've ever
that's annoying that's just annoying
oh [ __ ] idiot
ex-boyfriend was texting another woman
found a message that said i can't get
you out of my head when i confronted
when i confronted him
told me she was the biggest kylie
minogue fan and i was being crazy the
guys are wild
oh my man said she was singing lyrics i
just can't get you out of my face no
guys are going to hell man kylie minogue
fan you know
found a panty in his closet and he said
it that it belonged to his late mum and
he smells it for good luck i believed
him
that's a lie you didn't believe surely
not
this is what she said brother
this is what she said brother i smell it
for good luck man even threw in the
smell thing in there
not even that's all i've got for her or
whatever
[ __ ] hell
[Music]
my mate found her boyfriend actively on
tinder and he said that he was looking
for his long-lost friend
some man
he had he had hickeys on his neck and he
told me the mosquitoes were particularly
vicious last night
yeah that's funny
[ __ ] sake that's funny
oh jesus man
he told me he needed time to himself but
he was in jail
oh wow i would lie if i was in pendo oh
so would i because my girl's going to
leave me so i'm lying so would i get
away with lying about being in pin i'm
going to lie
how are you how are you even
communicating this lie [ __ ] knows that's
the thing [ __ ] knows
my ex said he cheated because his sister
had an eating disorder and it was really
hard for him
so i had to just release tension with
this nut
that's the [ __ ] on the doorstep
wow sitting on the doorstep all over
again wow [ __ ] me man
huh all right this is a long one i don't
remember writing this one
i found a picture of my ex-husband in a
family photo with a woman and a baby
he told me a woman from work asked him
to give him to give her a ride to the
photo place the photographer noticed
they happened to be dressed alike and
asked him to jump in the photo shoot so
he
a bold did lie
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
mandem oh we need to do better than this
man oh my god we need to do better than
this man oh [ __ ]
that's your wife and kids man will lie
mal will lie to avoid everything
any confrontation in his head it made
sense it made sense and he said oh
that's true wow how do you come up with
that on the cuff i don't know brother
how is that possible
jesus christ i asked him to jump in so
he did oh that's hilarious that is
hilarious
said the woman i caught him cheating
with
is going up
oh my god go on now go go go go go go go
go nah
said the woman
he said that the woman i caught him
cheating with is going to open a rape
case against him if you don't break up
no
no no no no no no
wow
i caught him in bed naked with another
woman his reply are you going to believe
me or your lying eyes with all his might
bro
with all his might you know [ __ ] it out
all right last one last one all right
cool
found out my ex was cheating on me with
my sister because he because he called
her babe and his excuse was i was
teaching her how to flirt
amanda i understand man
it's um
i've told some lies in my day so have i
but [ __ ] hell man these are so like
they're so
obviously a lie
but it's like how are you coming up with
these things you know
they're blatantly lies but they're so
funny that it's
they're believable in a sense because
they're just so ridiculous it's so
ridiculous it makes it so believable
yeah because no one else is saying this
but mandela yeah
yeah and it's all isolated incidents yes
yeah yeah this my man hasn't repeated
the same thing twice oh 100 it's nuts
brother wow
so oh yeah but yeah it's um that was a
funny one for me when i was reading them
that was a funny one yeah what one did i
see on i think the only one i read is
funny enough not one you even read out
was that something like she said i found
high heels under his bed and he says he
wears them to change the light bulbs
yo
i think i saw that one sweeted me
sweetie change the light bulbs who can
think of something so quickly
liars bro
liars can that's it men to be fair back
in the day when i was a younger man i
used to lie i know you did james i used
to lie
i used to lie
so to be fair some of them aren't too i
i'm thinking now like right how do mine
think of these things but there's a
couple lies i've told when i was younger
that could make that list
i'm not even gonna say that when you're
on the spot when you're put in a corner
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i know
what you mean yeah
there's some there's someone there that
would make that one i'm not even gonna
say what it is
the one that you always bring up would
make it there of course the screensaver
thing
[Laughter]
he's spoken about this one here have we
actually spoken about what we have
brother are you sure this is priest 100
i remember priesthood
pre-first dude yeah all right i couldn't
believe it when you told me
all for some time i couldn't believe it
brother
i could have been that would definitely
make the list
that would
definitely
make the list i don't remember what was
going through my mind when i said that
[ __ ] bro i don't even think it's i don't
even remember saying it i just remember
telling you that's what i said
i wasn't proud of it i don't even
remember saying i don't even know who
the girl was i don't remember the
situation i just remember telling you
it was too funny james oh god that was
too funny but yeah morrow's story is bad
about liars mandem elias i mean women
are liars women are also liars they're
um
they're so smart with it because women
don't lie
and then keep quite like for this for
example
i use why the [ __ ] you got high heels oh
babes i used them to change the [ __ ]
light bulb yeah
like she's gonna have so much
retaliation for that yeah
women they will lie to you and then keep
the conversation going so you didn't
have a chance to remember that you just
lied to you
women will hit you with the
oh babes why is there a homeboy shoes
under your bed it's like
the fact that you're looking under my
bed is the real issue do you understand
how toxic that is
who had do you understand the toxic
behavior this is why i don't feel safe
that's what
this is why i don't feel safe in my own
home
this is why i'm when i'm talking about
marriage counseling there's that you
don't want to hear it feel like this is
why i don't feel safe you've forgotten
about the crepes all your rings yes
marriage counselling all you're hearing
now is marriage counselling you've
forgotten about the creps
liars
you know what i mean yeah there would
never be a list of women because we
don't even remember when they lied
exactly because they've taken us so far
left
we don't even remember what the argument
was
[ __ ] they never stick to the argument
yeah [ __ ] it's always our fault when
it's our time to argue that's our fault
it flips back on us oh it's hilarious it
is hilarious when you look at it from
like hindsight and the third person is
[ __ ] hilarious oh [ __ ] me oh
but yeah that was funny um anyway guys
love to have you this monday as always
you know you know what to do if you want
to get the bonus episode on thursday
make sure you head on over to
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
thank you so much for your time and
attention and as always guys love love
love gang gang
[Music]